[Music]
let's go to hannah in
fort wayne hannah what's going on
hi how are you good how are you
i'm pretty good that's good
anyone says like oh pretty good you're
not so what's
up um yeah so i'm 33 years old um
i never necessarily thought i had an
anger issue
um it never was visible in my childhood
or anything like that
i think of myself as a pretty easy going
person but
your life is telling you that you have
an anger issue
well i mean me when i i mean it's very
evident that i do but
it has to do with my marriage um so
you know it's it has to do with when i
make a mistake which in marriage you do
um you know i do not ever
ever make him oh that's nice i'm totally
kidding i made like seven this morning
okay so whenever you make a mistake then
what
um so then you know i'll apologize for
it and say yeah
you know i did that um he'll he'll ask
me
you know why did you do that and i'll
kind of explain
or something and then he'll say well
you're making excuses
um and then i'm not not making excuses
i'm trying to
to not you know do it again i'm trying
to just
you know talk through it and um and then
you know he'll say you just need to just
literally when i make a mistake
say just i don't know i guess he doesn't
want me to ever talk about
anything of why and just own up to it um
but you know i did apologize um but then
what are these mistakes hannah like is
it like he keeps coming home and his
best friend is
it in your bedroom is it this mistake or
is it like
i didn't take the trash out no um i mean
it started early on
um like if i say things uh in front of
his friends or family
um that you know upsets him or
embarrasses him even if it's like you
know
jordan doesn't like to eat vegetables um
you know that he doesn't like if i say
that necessarily
um so and i to i'm a very blunt honest
that's a struggle for me i mean i
i'm just making conversation i might i
mean and i do say something i shouldn't
say
and i understand that at the same time i
can't
guarantee i'll never do that again so
one of the cornerstones
of somebody who is in a relationship
with somebody who is emotionally
immature
is they for instance
are sitting somewhere and somebody
brings up vegetables and you say
oh he's not gonna eat that and then
suddenly he gets his feelings
like that is becomes a death blow to his
soul
right mm-hmm and then at home it becomes
a whole thing
how dare you put me on blast in front of
my friends and family and you're like
dude i'm sorry i forgot about the don't
thing about vegetables thing like i
don't want to hear it you just don't
even
you i don't you're just making excuses
right
what happens in short order is you start
feeling crazy
and this is and use this this is
like the gas lights burn brightly in
hannah's home in fort wayne indiana
okay and you start feeling crazy
and then all of a sudden you start
trying to filter everything that you say
and every joke you tell and every like
okay is this oak is this okay
and that bar moves
because when somebody who's when a great
gaslighter gets a hold of somebody they
start that that finish line there's
never a moment when it would
then it will be you didn't look at me
enough or you kept looking at that guy
or why are you talking to my mom more
than me
and you're like okay i'll solve for that
problem and then pretty soon you're just
sitting at home
not doing anything right and you feel
insane
and then you get raged out right and so
insanity i often like to describe as
like being in a
like my shoulders are clenched right now
your whole situation's making me crazy
and i'll get crazy on this show this is
one that makes me laugh my skin crawl
uh it's like being in a pet kennel and
then eventually you just rage like you
just start rattling the the ken
the the cage and then the person who's
gaslighting you goes
c c and then you go oh i just did that
i've never done that what's happening i
must be crazy and it just all reinforces
itself in this weird nutty dance
does that make sense yeah that sounds
exactly right
oh god i can't stand this okay
how long have you been married to this
guy
about nine and a half years okay has
this been going on forever or is it
slowly just moving and moving and moving
and moving
no it started early on okay yeah right
away
okay so here's i'm gonna tell you
two things this uh this ends one of
three ways not two ways one of three
ways
number one it ends with
tragically some separation of some sort
and you are completely nutty you are
cooked and he is self-righteous
indignant and justified and it ends with
somebody having an affair or somebody
just imploding
okay it's something just blows up right
because here's what happens
and you can tell me if i'm right or
wrong you stop
you start keeping secrets you stop
telling him about things that happened
at work you
stop telling him about a way you feel
about something
and then eventually you will find
someone else to talk to
yes that has happened yes and
he will whether he cognitively knows it
or not
he will feel that you stopped talking to
him
and he has to connect he's a person and
he's going to find somebody to connect
to
and all of a sudden it's everybody's in
la la land and they didn't mean to get
there but that's here's where we are
right so that's step number one step
number two
everybody just slowly drowns and you
wake up and you've been married for 20
years and you're roommates
you don't like him he doesn't like you
your kids are just whatever
and you go to baseball games and sit by
each other usually with a kid in the
middle
right and it's just a slow suffocation
or the third is somebody
turns all the lights on stops the music
and stops this dance that's been going
on for nine years now
and says i love you too much to let you
continue to say i'm not a good person
because i talk about vegetables
you've got to grow up and deal with your
emotional immaturity
i do love you and yes i want to honor
and respect your boundaries and if you
don't want me talking about our marriage
or whatever out in public fine
also you knew who you married and i'm
loud and i'm fun and i like to be silly
and i like to make jokes and that's the
way i show love and yes i go too far
and now i'm talking to myself here by
the way hannah
and i know there's certain like there's
just certain things on this show i've
talked about and my wife has said hey
i heard from a friend um that this came
up she didn't listen to the show
and um she said hey that's iris don't
talk about that and she was right
and i wasn't trying to be mean or rude
or but that was fair
um but that line is not just continuing
to move right
but somebody's got to throw a flag and
say i'm going to see a marriage
counselor i'd love for you to come with
us because i think our marriage is in
trouble
and i'm telling you right now it is in
trouble okay
um you should be able to be you and at
the same time be respectful and treat
your husband with dignity
and at the same time he should be able
to be him and treat you with dignity and
respect
and this just sounds like a
it just sounds like the toilet bowl is
starting to spin faster and faster and
faster
and somebody's gotta hit the pause
button am i right
yeah well and we have uh done marriage
counseling two different times um
both of me saying
we need this because i'm like i'm a
crazy person
you know i'm so like i i need help you
know and
one time he didn't want to do it and i
was like okay well i'm just going to go
by myself i'm just going to do it you
know
and and then after a few sessions this
is my pastor's
wife you know said we need to get him
here and
um so yeah we have done that that's my
other concern is i don't know
i feel like i'm always you know and and
to be honest i did tell him about this
call today because i
oh i just lost your hand he's still
there i want to make sure
there you go okay you know if he's not
comfortable i don't want to do it yeah
oh
yeah i'm i'm here can you hear me yeah i
got your back
there's a storm okay um but uh
but yeah we've we've been down this road
before okay
um and you know i'm always the one that
says we need help
um so that that's also a concern
it is but he has no incentive to get
help because
he has no incentive to get help because
you
change every time and you're the crazy
one
right so there's no incentive
okay there's there's nothing in his
world that is rattling his world
because every time you rattle it
you fix it you stop doing your thing
gotcha and so number one
are you crazy
no i don't think so okay now
a lot of crazy people don't know they're
crazy hannah or is it you
uh i i
i don't think so but i do get really
frustrated when i'm
when i do apologize and then and it's
like i'm expected to be perfect and i'm
like that's impossible
it is you're right you're right it's me
i mean it is
so i i've never and i've never been
treated this way before i've never
i mean this is all so i don't think i am
but i've also never
been in this position before exactly
that's right
so um oh
man do you have a relationship with his
parents
yeah yeah we have good relationship with
both both sides okay
um i want you to read a book called
um gosh i've just lost it it's
about emotionally mature parents um
adult adult kids adult children of
emotionally immature parents i want you
to read that book
okay okay and it's a book for
adult children who are trying to figure
out why they are why they are
but and it talks about their parents but
i've
also seen couples go oh i live in this
now
okay i want you to read that book and if
it hits home
maybe he'll read it too ultimately i
think you're going to need to find
a therapist that is a relational life
therapist and that's out of the school
of
terrence real uh terry real you've got
to find a therapist that will take your
husband on
and most marriage and family therapists
won't do that
and it's a shame but some and that will
take you on too
because i know you're not perfect in
this deal um but i also know
nine years of scar tissue becomes nine
years of scar tissue right
so i guarantee if he was on the phone
um he would be telling me another story
and his story probably makes sense too
okay and if he wants to call me i'd love
to talk to him also
i don't want to paint him as the evil
guy here but i
yeah what you're telling me is just a
playbook and i've seen it over and over
and over again
okay and i'm just telling you it doesn't
end well
and so i want somebody whether that's
you flip on all the lights and say
i'm gonna go take care of me because
that's at the end of the day you've
already tried marriage therapy
you've got to find somebody that will
take him on um
call somebody and let them know and sit
down and say i want to get well i want
to take care of me
that doesn't mean you're trying to
figure out ways that you can be perfect
that means that you are trying to figure
out ways to deal with a
heavy gaslight or somebody who's
emotionally mature somebody who's
struggling on their own
that doesn't have the skill set to be in
a marriage right now
that doesn't know how to communicate
well right
and here's the other thing hannah i've
ganged up on him a little bit
or a lot if there are things like hey i
don't want you talking about our sex
life with our friends
then don't do that right there's a
balance here too
um hey i don't work out enough and i'm
embarrassed about my body don't call me
you know fatso whatever the thing is
that there is a line there right
um that make sure that you're honoring
and treating him with dignity too
um but don't be in a relationship i'm
not i'm going to tell you get divorced
i'm telling you don't be in a
relationship where
somebody is constantly making you feel
insane making you feel
crazy making you feel like you're evil
and you're sitting i don't
i don't know what's going on here you
got to go see somebody so get that book
we'll link to it in the show notes here
and then you start seeing somebody today
call somebody today
that you haven't talked to before and
get straight to the point i live with a
with a um fire breathing gas lighter
and i don't know what to do anymore and
i gotta learn some skills on how to
handle this
invite him if he'll come and uh but he's
gonna have to have a therapist that will
take him on
right thank you so so much for the call
hannah ah we'll be thinking about you i
know those are hard hard hard hard hard
and dehana's husband listening to this
dude i bet you're a good guy
in fact i almost count on it i bet
you're a good guy
and i bet that everything feels personal
and feels like you're being attacked by
a woman who loves you and once you hear
me say i don't think
she doesn't love you i think she does
love you a lot i want you to have the
courage and the strength to say
maybe it's me maybe i'm playing a part
in this maybe
i've got a key role that i'm playing
here maybe i've got to learn some new
skills
maybe every time my feelings get hurt um
it isn't always somebody trying to go
after me or hurt me maybe i need to
learn
some emotional intelligence or some
relational intelligence i need to learn
some skills
i have the courage to do that man and go
open-handed don't make a therapist take
you on
go say hey i'm gonna be vulnerable here
i get
take things so personally and i know
this woman loves me oh i got some things
i got to learn
go be brave man go be brave and uh call
me back and let me know how that goes
all right i'd love to talk to you